so and actually seth rogen produces the
show right so did you have to audition
for him
was that nerve-wracking he did it was he
is uh
he you guys picked the most intimidating
picture i've ever seen of seth rogen
he's like audition for me please oh my
god you sounded like him yeah that was
good
i do my best no i had to audition for
him which was super nerve-wracking
because he's one of my heroes him and
his writing partner evan goldberg and i
remember i was pacing in the hallway
going over my lines and he hadn't showed
up yet and then like
seemingly a mile away i could hear like
i could hear his like iconic laugh
and i was like oh he's here and then
once we got into the room
um it was insane because he was reading
butcher
on the day butcher is a character in the
show who has a very thick
uh cockney accent so it was seth rogen
not doing the accent but saying lines
that involved a lot of
hardcore cockney slang which my brain
was really struggling to understand you
know what reality i was in it would be
like
i would say a line and he would say we
gotta get him in the boot and then we're
gonna bug her off
like it was is he trying to throw you
off your game is this what it was like
i i i don't think so he's a very very
nice guy it was just one of those
moments where i was so nervous
and i was just i was so crazy
no i don't think he would intentionally
do that but memorable disabled seems
like somebody that might mess with
someone that's the only reason